of a 17-month
year-old girl bella ray burch
bella ray has lost her life in the most
unimaginably terrible circumstances and
our thoughts are first and foremost with
the family and the wider community at
this devastating time
our specialist family liaison officers
are providing the family of ballarat
with support
and officers will remain in the area in
the coming days to provide further
reassurance and support for the wider
community
at this stage we understand that the
family dog they had bought just a week
earlier has attacked belaret inside the
family home
ballarat was taken by ambulance to
hospital by paramedics but despite the
best efforts of police officers
at scene the paramedics and doctors
sadly bellaray died as a result of her
injuries yesterday afternoon
it has left a family and a community
grieving and in complete shock
during the incident the dog was handed
over to police at the address and has
been humanely destroyed
detailed investigations are continuing
into this tragic event
forensic examinations to determine the
dog's breed are ongoing and we are
working to identify all the previous
owners of the dog so we can establish
its history
we want to continue to support the
family and the local community and
officers will remain at scene on bidston
avenue during the day today
i want to appeal to anyone who was in
the bidston avenue area yesterday
afternoon and witnessed anything or have
any information about the dog in
question to please come forward and
either speak to one of our officers or
contact merseyside police via our social
media desks and that can be done on
twitter
at maypole cc or merseyside police
contact center on facebook
alternatively if people don't want to
contact the police directly they can
contact the independent charity crime
stoppers that will be done uh
anonymously and that they can be
contacted online if you just search for
crime stoppers or contacted via
telephone on oh 800
triple five triple one that's 800 triple
five triple one thank you for your time